I've heard that recent studies have shown that radiation therapy for cancer could actually make things worse.
Is this true?
It is true. There are ambed recent studies that show that doing radiation therapy for cancer.
And it's typically, I think the studies were typically unsolved tissue.
It's not just recent studies. There's been studies over time that show that radiation and soft tissue
could actually make things worse.
So that's why I've never been a fan of radiation, unless it's a last-ditch effort that the cancer's growing too fast.
Because if you... I know one of the...
It never used to be this way, but about... I don't know. Maybe it was five, eight years ago.
The recommendations from a college is to breast cancer patients.
Now is that we have breast cancer. We need to do a mastectomy or a lumpectomy.
And then we need to do radiation. And we need to do chemotherapy.
Or you do chemotherapy first to shrink the lump.
And then do a lumpectomy or mastectomy. And then do radiation.
And then typically, if it's PR or ER positive, you'd use an astrosol or some other aroma-tasted inhibitor.
To me, that's just nonsense. If you're going to... oh, radiate the area because there could be leftover cancer cells.
Well, radiation in itself is a major cause of cancer.
So you're not radiating a specific site. You're not meeting that site that is known to be cancerous.
If you could pinpoint radiation and just hit this certain one centimeter site, that would be great, but radiation doesn't have a stop point.
So it's going to go through whatever tissue it took to get to that one centimeter site.
And then through the one centimeter site and then through the back of the person, it has an exit wound.
So you're going to be doing just as much damage on the entrance wound and the exit wound as you did on the site itself.
Well, we're going to target in different rays. So it's going to go at different angles.
So that you're going to have less radiation at each individual entrance wound and each individual exit wound.
So that you're not going to just destroy tissue at that site.
Yeah, but you're damaging the tissue enough to cause enough oxidative stress that could cause cancer at any of those given sites.
So I'm not a big fan of that.
So yes, recent studies and old studies have shown that radiation therapy.
It's known that cause cancer. It certainly can make things worse.
So I would say yes, that is true to them.